i mentioned i'm i'm living in the high
desert in northern
new mexico uh where there are a lot of
indigenous pueblos and archaeological
sites
and it was in the early 90s that i was
hiking through one of the archaeological
sites in the four corners area it's
chaco canyon some people maybe you've
been there some people know where that
is and i uh an indigenous man
uh was was coming the other direction he
stopped and talked to me on
on the path and he began telling me a
story
uh it was really interesting and he said
a long time ago
people in this part of the world lived
very differently they were close to the
earth they remembered
who they were they remembered their
relationship to the earth
to the sky to the past to the future to
time
he said then something happened and we
don't know exactly
what the something was but people got
lost
something happened and they began to
forget who they were
and they so longed for the connection
that they used to have with themselves
with one another
and with the earth and with the
ancestors they began
building things outside of their bodies
to remind them of who they are inside of
their bodies
and he said we live in that world today
we are still
cluttering our outer world with all of
this technology
and everything that we're building out
there
in some way mirrors mimics
what we already do in here and he said
we're going to keep doing this we will
clutter our world and clutter our lives
until
we come to this realization he said and
then we will let that external
technology go
so the life and the world looks simpler
but we have become
much more sophisticated and much more
evolved beings and i thought
wow you know i thought i was just on a
hike in chaco canyon and that
that was a very very deep philosophy
well i'm i'm a scientist
i'm a degree earth scientist with a
strong background in
life sciences biological sciences and
math physics and computer science
and i say that because it helps me to
stay current danica with all of the
research
that's not always easy to read it's it's
published in very obscure journals
very technical language and you know
life is simple nature is simple science
is simple
until we make it complex with with his
language and with
the formulas and and the math if you
want to engineer it you need those
things but to understand it you do not
so i have the opportunity to
to stay current with the discoveries and
all the new discoveries are confirming
what that native man
said to me that that we are
we are literally a soft technology so
let me
share what that means and then i'm going
to tie that into the answer about the
simulation
the average human body we're told has
about 50 trillion or so
cells you know give or take when i was
in school
back in 1950s 60s early 70s i was taught
that those cells were like little sacks
of
of salt water you know saline you know
there's some other stuff going on but
nothing like what we know today now we
know
that every one of those 50 trillion
cells has
about .07 volts of electrical potential
and you say well you know that's that's
not very much and you're right but you
do the math
50 trillion cells times .07 volts i've
done this so many times i'll tell you
is 3.5 trillion volts of electrical
potential
now if you could harness that and direct
that
to states of healing or intuition
or or extraordinary states of cognition
or resilience or building a powerful
immune system man who doesn't want that
you know in the age of covet
but it doesn't stop there because every
one of those cells
also is functions and essentially is in
our body it's a capacitor
it's a resistor it's a transistor these
these are all electrical components that
massage electrical information
every cell in our body receives photons
of light that is
information and energy and we not only
receive it we transmit we are
constantly transmitting photons of light
into this field that we haven't talked
about yet that underlies all existence
we are in
direct communication it's a conversation
it's a two-way conversation
with this field every cell in our body
the surface of our
because of covid everybody knows of what
a cell looks
like now and about the receptors on the
cells those receptors are antenna
and they are constantly receiving light
information
and electrical and magnetic information
the dna
in the nucleus of our cells our antenna
essentially the genes that make up the
dna
our antennae the higher frequencies we
are gated circuits
all of this is a very very different way
of looking at the human body and and
this is
where we go back to the first part of
this conversation we are the only form
of life
danica that we know of today maybe
others
elsewhere in the cosmos i'm sure there
are but we're the only form of life on
earth
that has the ability to self regulate
all of this soft technology
and to do it consciously at will and on
demand
other forms of life may do it by
instinct we're the only form of life
that can sit down
in a chair in a moment in time and say
in this moment i
choose to access this this soft
technology within me
and create a stronger immune system or
awaken my
my anti-aging and longevity enzymes you
know who doesn't want that
we're the only form of life that can do
this we are
technology we are a soft technology
interfacing with a field of energy and
information
that modern science is only beginning to
acknowledge
so we begin to think from that
perspective now i'm going to go back
there's an emerging
philosophy that everything that we
create
that consciousness
informs itself through its creations
so that means everything that we create
in the world
out there is telling us something about
ourselves in here this it's a it's a
mind blower it's a really interesting
way of thinking so all the art
all the sculptures all the music i'm a
musician when i'm
when i'm not being an author all the
music that we create
uh the movies hollywood look at the
films that people are most drawn true to
the blockbusters and and look at the
themes of those films the matrix for
example
told us that there's a world that we
can't see that we participate
in that influences a world that we can
see
the movie avatar reminded us of our
relationship to to nature in the natural
world
inception was all about dreams and
dreams within dreams
and the young people i love this young
people are
so turned on man they are fired up
over the superheroes the avengers and
wonder woman
all reminding them that there is a
potential within them
that maybe they have yet to fully tap
that we have abilities that we're only
beginning to understand so
if consciousness informs itself
through its creations then that
principle would extend to the technology
so i am not surprised that the internet
that we built mimics our neural networks
within our bodies
yeah i'm not surprised that blockchain
technology
that is revolutionizing finance
and and what money even means in the
world
and bringing peace to nations because
they don't have
to compete for natural resources for the
old kinds of money we used to think
about
i'm not supply surprise that blockchain
technology
mimics human dna in a blockchain
technology
there is a record of every transaction
that has ever occurred from the very
first transaction in
our genome is a record of every genetic
transaction that has ever transpired
from the time that we first emerged on
this planet
so this pr this is such a powerful
principle consciousness
informs itself through its creations
so if this is true now we
are using technology to build
simulations
and we've only had computers danica you
know i mean really
high-speed computers we've had them for
maybe 40 years
and look at where we are now we are
creating simulations that are almost
indistinguishable from everyday life
so the question now that scientists are
asking
this is where the the really intense
podcast gets really really intense
it's called the forbidden question the
forbidden question
is are we living in what is called a
base reality or are we living in a
virtual
reality or a simulated reality that is
reflecting
a base reality somewhere else now a lot
of people think you know well this is
science fiction
if consciousness informs itself through
its creations and we have made
all of these movies about these
simulations what are we asking ourselves
to remember
so where this really took a turn i mean
it's interesting you know
conversation at starbucks uh until 2001
2001 the first scientific experiments
were run
and a paper was written by a man named
nick bostrom and maybe you've
you've had him on the program or other
people have referenced him i don't know
uh but he asked the question he said are
we living in
in a virtual reality and he he set up
a very complex algorithm and ran the
algorithm on the computer and the bottom
line
is that the odds are greater that we are
in a simulation
than that we are not in the simulation
so that that was 2001 2014
this went further and they began
a series of of physics experiments
regarding reality and this is one of the
first as you were covering all of the
ground you know what is our relationship
to reality
and the bottom line to these experiments
is what they found is that our
physical reality only
exists when something is observing it
and this this ties back to experiments
that were done early in the the 20th
century
called the double slit very famous
double slit experiments
that atoms or quantum particles
will behave one way when they're not
being observed
and they will behave another way when
they are when they're not being observed
they're waves that you can't see
when they are observed through a camera
or a recording mechanism or human
consciousness
then those waves collapse in the
particles that become our
reality where this gets really
interesting
is this is precisely the way we build
our simulations today
our computers can't hold if if you're
going to have a simulation
of a jungle your computer cannot hold
all of the information to make every
leaf and all the bark on all the trees
and all the insects and the rocks and
the water
in that jungle and just hold it there
when when it's not being used
so the computer doesn't do that the
computer only puts those there
when that part of the simulation is
going to be used
the experiments strongly suggest that
our reality
works in a very very similar fashion and
that we
are the odds are greater that we are
than that we are not living in some kind
of a
a simulation or a uh a simulated reality
or a virtual reality